they are beloved a symbol of the west
and part of the american landscape
the i-team has covered wild horses and
the issues surrounding them for years
now an investigation has revealed some
of them are being
sold for slaughter the i-team's vanessa
murphy here live in studio with more
denise and brian there's a few issues
here how the government captures wild
horses and burros
what the government does with these
animals after that
and now whether they're being sold and
killed for meat
you have these like iconic american
you know symbols of freedom that are
being brutally butchered and
shipped off for foreign horse meat
markets overseas
executive director suzanne roy says the
american wild horse campaign
teamed up with the new york times for an
in-depth investigation
which revealed wild horses are being
sold for slaughter
we're calling it slaughter gate it
happens about every decade
the blm gets exposed for sending horses
federally protected wild horses ambrose
to slaughter
and the reason this is happening is
because the blm
keeps rounding up wild horses by law the
bureau of land management
is authorized to capture wild horses and
boroughs for the health and productivity
of public lands
wild horse advocates point to cattle
ranchers and
their interest in the land for their
livestock in recent years
there has been a record-breaking number
of roundups
in some instances causing injuries and
deaths to the animals
the ones that survive are kept in
federal holding pens
through a federal program an individual
is offered one
thousand dollars to adopt one horse
but roy says some people were taking the
money
selling the animals and through the
investigation and tracking
it was discovered some animals were
headed to be killed for human
consumption
it was just horrific and it just breaks
your heart
when you see people under false
pretenses say we're going to adopt a
pony
democratic congresswoman dina titus is a
longtime
advocate for wild horses according to
the blm
as of march 2020 there were nearly 47
thousand wild horses in the state
that's more than half of all the wild
horses in the country
congresswoman titus and roy say they
support a method of birth control
through
darts for the animals advocates say it's
more cost effective and
more humane than roundups but so far the
blm
has shown resistance we've never come up
with somebody in the blm who really
cares about this and i think now
secretary holland will be the person who
can be a good partner
for us the i-team's request for an
interview with the new secretary of
interior who oversees the blm
was declined the american wild horse
campaign is now calling for an
investigation
into the adoption program it wants
employees held accountable
criminal prosecution for those who sold
the animals for slaughter
and for lawmakers to step in
congresswoman titus says
gradually there is more interest in
legislation
but there is also a challenge sometimes
it's hard to get through
the agriculture committee though because
it's so dominated
by ranching interests
congresswoman titus says she receives
the most amount of letters about this
issue people from all over the country
showing support for wild horses
even if they've never personally seen
one